patrick amateurs de décider alors
l'auteur si omar wade patrick t'as pas
envie de rentrer tout seul c'est sympa
patrick mais pourquoi pas t'as pas envie
de rentrer chez toi quand tu vois c'est
quoi cette histoire de culotte non mais
parfois les gens jettent des projectiles
payer parfois des choses qui arrivent
avec des numéros de téléphone de ses
culottes avec des numéros
oui oui mais comment sait pas d'où elles
viennent les culottes les bars appelé au
casino de paris
quand j'ai fait là le dernier concert
acoustique ont été prêtés que deux
randonnées la guitare mais ça sonne il
est pas mal et il est nahla qui est
monté sur le bord du du balcon de boue
c'est très très dur et je fais remarquer
patrick nous c'est que valérie benaïm a
un nouveau mec et s'achète patoche mais
ce n est pas lui s'appelle pas tort il
est possible de donner les jo surnommé
non sans le sésame dans mon portail
l'appela plus tout ça ils ont viré dit
de pas me [ __ ] sous un pseudonyme
annoncé lui qu'il gagne il fait du yoga
numérique n aura celui qui perd il
s'agit de la baisse
[Applaudissements]
alors allez lensois allez c'est parti a
eu sa bio a par ailleurs versé par dix
mais il renvoie le [ __ ] jouer comme ça
pendant deux heures pour tous ces prêts
moi aussi
patrick si vous voulez je fais ça un
petit point dom la lévée les petits
points rad est d'accord un petit poêle
au sénat jusqu'à 1,3 à redire les allées
d'air de paris c'est la couleur directe
à l'image il commença toilettes communes
jeu dernier patrick bernier fois ça se
joue sur ce court ressources que plus
lointain répartissez la balle de match
[Applaudissements]
destiné là on l'a fait devenir on lui a
dit qu'ils avaient en fait un casting
pour un nouveau jeu télé dans lequel
plusieurs candidats de plusieurs jeux
allaient s'affronter mais qu'avant il
fallait se présenter sans voir les
autres à des radars auquel à un bandeau
elle a un casque
elle c'est une part le wali et je vais
demander au public de faire le silence
absolu
elle sait pas qu'elle va voir patrick
bruel dans un instant estinnes femme
christine bonsoir m'entendez oui je vous
fais dans la vie christine je suis en
formation actuellement
est ce que vous connaissez ma voix j'ai
l'impression de vous et ceux qui pensent
qu'on a déjà
c'est qu'ils ressemblent je crois que
c'est cyril hanouna alors oui c'est moi
qui va animer le jeu d'accord et je vais
l'animé avec quelqu'un d'autre
oui la lune dire si vous reconnaissez la
voix de celui qui va animer le jeu avec
moi bonsoir christine
vous l'avez reconnu c'est patrick bruel
c'est patrick bruel alors il n'a pas pu
venir et nous a laissé un petit message
pour vous ce qui va animer le jeu et
vous vous le connaissez vous l'aimez
bien je suis fan depuis combien de temps
plus de 27 ans vous avez déjà rencontré
j'ai vu en concert mais y ait jamais eu
l'occasion de le rencontrer
peut-être que savoir qui fait le joue
avec nous ça vous ferait plaisir c'est
un rêve vous voulez participer au jeu
maintenant bat le fer le casting avec
nous allons si on va écouter on va faire
le casting maintenant merci ma vie parce
que c'est grâce à la grille aux siens